[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le 7 8 c'est
votre émission sur TV 78 pour bien
démarrer la soirée dans les Yvelines
avec au programme de l'actualité des
infos pratiques et des idées de sortie
voici le programme de ce 5 décembre
l'hôpital André Mignot du centre
hospitalier de Versailles victimes d'une
cyberata que le site de 700 lits
installés au Chesnay rock en cours a été
visé samedi soir depuis le système
informatique a été coupé pour limiter
les dégâts l'accueil des passions est
très limité et réorganisé une cellule de
crise a été ouverte le détail à suivre
dans nos informations du jour les abords
de la gare de La Verrière vont être
totalement transformés d'ici quelques
années un futur écoquartier garbecane
sera aménagé au sein de cette zone
d'aménagement concerté 1500 logements et
60000 m² de pôle d'activité économique
seront construits on en parle avec
Nicolas Dainville maire de la verrière
et vice-président de 50 ans en Yvelines
et puis zoom sur tiekar depuis 2019 ce
dispositif culturel est proposé aux
jeunes de Mantes-la-Jolie il s'agit
d'ateliers de théâtre comme moyen
d'expression pour aborder les
problématiques sociales liées à la
banlieue
et on parle de ce dispositif avec
plusieurs invités il y en a déjà un qui
m'a rejoint au plateau serudy enzinga
bonsoir bonsoir à l'origine de ce projet
tiekar c'est une association c'est
jeunesse sans frontières quelles sont
les missions de jeunesse sans frontières
donc du coup les missions de jeunesse
sont frontières se le découpe en 3 donc
avec un volet culturel humanitaire et
social donc voilà l'idée c'était
d'accompagner les jeunes à travers ces
trois volets et donc trois volets et
dans ces trois volets il y a des actions
et le dispositif checker on en dira un
petit peu plus tout à l'heure mais en
quelques mots qui écars je le disais
c'est du théâtre pour pour parler de
sujet pour pour être un moyen
d'expression pour ces jeunes c'est
exactement pour prendre confiance en soi
pour prendre la parole pour libérer la
parole et on en parlera tout à l'heure
avec d'autres invités sur ce sujet
tiekar sur ce plateau également les
journalistes de la rédaction de TV 78
Michael et nidoro bonsoir avez-vous tout
à l'heure les résultats sportifs du
week-end et ce que s'est-il passé dans
le département comme d'habitude les
résultats sportifs du weekend il y a eu
notamment une très belle victoire de
Poissy en National 2 voisins bretonnés
aussi qui a gagné dans première division
de district et on aura avec nous des
invités exactement Axel durillac qui est
avec nous Axel Axel qui va nous parler
de ça très belle 3e place lors des
championnats du monde mais là de bronze
donc voilà chapeau
pour moi c'est déjà du passé on va dire
les prochaines objectives c'est ça c'est
ça on aura l'occasion d'en parler tout à
l'heure Axel il y a aussi votre coach
René baby avec un fidèle de splato aussi
TV 78 qui vous accompagne à chacune de
vos venus on aura l'occasion de lui
poser aussi
à peu près et maintenant troisième place
au Championnat du Monde
bien sûr sur TV 78 également avec nous
Régine rage de la rédaction tv78 bonsoir
avez-vous tout à l'heure les
informations du jour on viendra
forcément sur cette cyberattaque dont
était victime l'hôpital André Mignot
c'est Rocancourt dans cette édition
également le bilan de l'édition 2022 du
téléthon nous étions notamment dans deux
communes ce week-end à Magny-les-Hameaux
et aux Clayes-sous-Bois toute cette
semaine aussi notre série nous allons
suivre un chef cuisinier c'est Jérémy en
bielle et on va voir avec lui de quelle
manière il s'approvisionne pour préparer
des plats locaux et notamment une
recette traditionnelle une recette qu'on
connaît bien dans les Yvelines autour de
la poule de Houdan mais avant tout cela
petit coup d'oeil à la météo de demain
[Musique]
ce sera brumeux dans la matinée dans les
Yvelines et très frais pensez à vous
couvrir pour éviter les virus de l'hiver
qui circulent en ce moment comptez 2
degrés à Mantes-la-Jolie Versailles et
Houdan ce sera un degré à Rambouillet
dans l'après-midi les températures
n'augmenteront que très peu 3 degrés à
Rambouillet ce sera à 4 degrés à
Versailles ou dans et Mantes-la-Jolie ce
mardi 6 décembre nous fêterons et
Nicolas
et tout de suite les informations du
jour avec vous Régine ralech l'hiver
arrive à grands pas et la météo
justement ne manque pas nous le rappeler
dans les Yvelines ce matin les premiers
flocons sont tombés dans les Yvelines
mais d'après les prévisions de Météo
France la neige ne s'installera pas dans
le département il n'y aura donc pas de
quoi faire de batailles de neige et des
bonhommes de neige
sur cet aspect alors direction à présent
le généraux en cours c'est l'information
du week-end régime le centre hospitalier
de Versailles était victime d'une
cyberattaque victime d'une cyber attaque
samedi soir l'hôpital André Mignot de
Versailles a déclenché son plan blanc
qui permet de prendre des mesures
exceptionnelles en cas de crise vers 21h
des ordinateurs affichés un message
concernant des informations dérobées
pour limiter la propagation sur le
réseau la direction à couper l'ensemble
du système d'informations une cellule de
crise a également été ouverte on écoute
le témoignage du maire du chêné
Rocancourt au micro de Patrick Jacques
de Dixmude l'idée c'est d'accompagner
un peu qui est en gestion de crise le
temps qu'il faudra donc sans doute
jusqu'à Noël pour s'assurer qu'ils ont
l'ensemble des moyens donc des hier le
ministre de la Santé François Brune est
venu indiquer que le SAMU zonal donc le
5000 de France était venu apporter des
hier soir des moyens notamment en
matière de biologie pour revenir pallier
les les défaillances liés à l'attaque
donc on a en terme matériel on n'aura
pas trop de soucis je pense que le la
solidarité va fonctionner derrière il
faut qu'on s'assure que les personnels
tiennent dans la durée
l'ARS Île-de-France Agence Régionale de
Santé invite les patients à composer
directement le 15 en cas d'urgence
l'établissement peut aussi compter sur
la solidarité régionale certains
patients ont été transférés dans
d'autres établissements franciliens
comme l'explique Alexandre moquedet
directeur de la communication au centre
hospitalier de Versailles si patients
ont été transférés par précaution sur
des patients qui étaient
particulièrement instables étant donné
que le système d'information était
indisponible pour faire le suivi et la
surveillance de ces patients au central
qui n'étaient pas possible on a préféré
les transférer une plante a été déposée
dimanche à l'hôpital et le parquet cyber
de Paris a été saisi sur ce dossier là
ainsi qui est l'autorité nationale en
matière de sécurité et de défense des
systèmes d'information va réaliser un
suivi des conséquences de l'attaque et
on continue à présent régime avec le
chiffre du jour 1800 1800 c'est le
nombre d'armes abandonnées par des
yvelinois auprès des forces de l'ordre
une opération nationale avait été lancée
le 25 novembre dernier par le ministère
de l'Intérieur et des Outre-mer le but
était de régulariser la situation des
détenteurs d'armes deux options étaient
à leur possibles les enregistrer ou les
abandonner de quel type d'armes
parle-t-on alors seuls les armes à feu
étaient ouvertes à l'enregistrement dans
le système d'information des armes
l'abandon lui concernait plus en plus
des armes à feu les armes deux points
les armes blanches et les petites
munitions alors tout autre chose à
présent c'est une nouvelle idée de
sortie du côté de Maurepas une salle de
réalité virtuelle ouvre aujourd'hui dans
la zone Paris Ouest à Maurepas c'est IVA
eSport virtual Arena le leader mondial
de sport virtuel qui ouvre sa dernière
salle en Île-de-France sa deuxième salle
pardon le concept des joueurs sont munis
d'un casque de réalité virtuelle d'un
fusil à pompe connectée et d'un sac à
dos il s'affronteront à ce déplaçant
librement au sein d'une arène de 500
mètres carrés
et notre dernière info du jour est
plutôt insolite Antoine Rey en habitant
de Houdan a pris l'avion ce matin
direction le Caire en Égypte son
objectif est de traverser le continent
jusqu'au cap qui se situe donc au sud de
l'Afrique au total il parcourera 12000
km pour le moment pas de billet retour
vers la France le cycliste ne s'interdit
donc pas de rejoindre l'Amérique du Sud
pour un autre périple merci Régine pour
toutes ces informations et si vous aussi
près de chez vous vous êtes témoin d'un
fait d'une information qui vous fait
réagir n'hésitez pas à nous le dire sur
les réseaux sociaux en utilisant le
hashtag 7 8 news
et un invité nous a rejoint en plateau
c'est Nicolas Dainville bonsoir bonsoir
maire de la commune de La Verrière vous
êtes aussi l'un des vice-président de 50
ans en Yvelines et aussi du département
des Yvelines avec vous on va parler de
ces travaux qui sont lancés à la
verrière alors il y a le réaménagement
de ce pôle gare Nord mais aussi cette
future ce futur EcoQuartier garbecane
qui a aussi un projet d'envergure pour
la ville je profite de votre présence de
mer en plateau pour faire réagir à l'une
des informations du week-end c'est cette
cyberattaque dont était victime à
l'hôpital André Mignot situé au Chesnay
Rocancourt vous en tant que mère en tant
qu'élu local quand vous voyez qu'un
hôpital peut subir une cyber-attaque on
sait que des collectivités ont pu aussi
faire l'objet de cyberattaque est-ce que
ça vous inquiète de voir ce genre
d'actualité bien sûr on est vraiment
dans des actes de terreur on a des
patients qui ont dû être transférés on a
des équipes qui sont totalement
déstabilisées le CIG le centre inter
départemental gestion a lui aussi subi
ce type de cyberattax ce qui nous dans
la ville de La Verrière nous a mis dans
une grande grande des difficultés pour
gérer les peines notamment de nos agents
pour récupérer les données
confidentielles donc on efface à des
menaces de plus en plus grandes et donc
il faut qu'on se protège et qu'on se
protège avec des moyens vraiment
efficaces on sait que la cybersécurité
est un élément fort en tout cas dans la
poétique de 50 ans en Yvelines de
l'agglomération qu'est-ce qu'on peut
faire localement pour éviter ce genre de
problème à l'avenir là c'est quand même
un hôpital qui est touché avec des
patients un personnel aussi Qui est
concerné du coup bah il faut qu'on fasse
attention chacun notre niveau les
particuliers il faut vraiment faire
gaffe sur les sollicitations sur
internet sur les demandes d'envoi de
code sur le cyber
les cyberattaques et puis il faut au
niveau collectif qu'on fasse aussi très
très attention
dans la manière dont on gère nos
messages dans la manière dont on protège
dans la manière dont on code nos
informations et c'est pour ça qu'à
Saint-Quentin on s'attaque au taureau
par les cornes avec des formations qui
sont labellisées par l'agglomération
pour former
jeune et moins jeune il y a beaucoup de
personnes qui se reconvertissent sur ces
métiers de la cybersécurité parce que
c'est un thème qui est vraiment
d'actualité alors je disais on parle
avec vous de sujets d'envergure pour la
verrière ils sont directement liés bien
sûr le premier c'est celui-ci les
travaux ont été lancés depuis février
2020 les travaux d'aménagement du
secteur nord de la gare de la verrière
qui sont actuellement en cours parmi les
opérations une nouvelle écostation de
bus création d'un parvis de 6000 m² d'un
parking relais de 900 places la fin
globale des travaux est prévu dans un an
alors la première étape de ce projet on
peut le dire c'est la première étape
d'un projet plus grande envergure qui
est l'aménagement du quartier guerbecane
on va en parler dans un instant mais on
regarde à présent le reportage de Julien
Leroy
un nouveau visage pour la gare de La
Verrière démarrée en février 2022 les
travaux d'aménagement du nouveau pôle
multimodal sont en cours objectif
fluidifier les transports en commun et
la circulation automobile dans ce
secteur traversé chaque jour par 25000
voyageurs c'est une demande globale
d'amélioration et effectivement
d'améliorer globalement le
fonctionnement des transports et
moderniser effectivement ce secteur qui
en avait bien besoin d'où aujourd'hui
cette mise en service de la gare
routière une gare routière toute neuve
qui représente plus de 850 mouvements
par jour
desservis par 11 lignes cet écostation
de bus permet un meilleur accueil des
usagers par rapport à l'ancienne gare
routière en complément un nouveau parvis
piétonnier de 6000 m² verra le jour en
septembre 2023 le passage souterrain
sera prochainement rénové avec de
nouveaux éclairages pour plus de
sécurité au total 11,5 millions d'euros
seront nécessaires à ces réaménagement
vraiment d'être fait parce que c'est une
gamme qui garde vraiment desservie c'est
un vieux il fallait renouveler et voilà
quoi tout ça dans un cadre paysager très
qualitatif puisqu'on plante plus de 165
arbres mais également plus de 23000
plantes couvrent seuls et graminées en
parallèle à nouveau parking relais de
900 places sera créée c'était difficile
sera 100% autonome en énergie grâce à
des panneaux photovoltaïques sa
livraison est prévue en mars 2023 pour
un coup de plus de 10 millions d'euros
les usagers qui auront des des passes
Navigo notamment annuels auront accès à
ce parking relais dans des conditions
préférentielles pour finalement un
stationnement beaucoup plus
adapté et beaucoup plus confortable les
chefs vont des travaux du pôle gare Nord
est prévu pour fin 2023 première étape
avant le démarrage du projet urbain
garbecane qui verra la construction de
1500 logements et 60000 mètres carrés de
pôle d'activités économiques
alors quelques chiffres Nicolas ville
5,7 millions de voyageurs transitent par
la gare de La Verrière par an il y a
deux lignes de Transilien qui passe par
cette gare qui sont les lignes Nui et 11
lignes de bus a été rappelé et ce qui a
été dit aussi à la fin de ce reportage
c'est que finalement une première étape
d'un grand projet pour le territoire de
la verrière c'est cette éco-quartier
garbecane qui va avoir le jour repenser
la garde à voir si une première étape
clé justement pour venir après sur ce
projet à garbecane bien sûr on avait une
guerre extrêmement vétue mais je me
souviens dire près d'une dizaine
d'années ou les élus déjà se
mobilisaient pour essayer de donner de
nouveaux moyens pour cette gare on
accueillait pas les les
usagers dans des conditions acceptables
également pour les personnes lutter
réduites ou les rampes d'accès n'étaient
même pas au nord sans parler du
souterrain qui était quasiment coup de
gorge et très anxiogène donc il fallait
vraiment mettre les moyens et tout cela
prend du temps mais les moyens avec la
région avec la SNCF avec l'agglomération
avec le département ce sont mis d'accord
pour pour faire le bon Schuler qu'on a
inauguré il y a maintenant à peu près
deux ans entre la verrière et Mortain
entre la verrière et Maurepas qui permet
un aménagement également sécurisé pour
les piétons pour les vélos pour les bus
le nouveau parking 900 places gratuits
pour les détenteurs du Pass Navigo
Annuel il y a eu toute une mobilisation
pour augmenter le nombre de places on
est passé à peu près de 500 qui était
programmé à plus de 900 914 pour être
précis qui sera à la pointe de
l'innovation énergétique puisque ça en
autoconsommation avec des panneaux
photovoltaïques qui vont être installés
on a également ce parvis piéton qui pour
la verrière est une une vraie
opportunité pour développer un vrai
quartier de la gare on avait une gare à
la verrière mais on n'avait pas un
quartier qui rayonnait autour de la gare
comme dans de nombreuses communes là on
aura comme la rappeler votre reportage
un beau par VIP piéton moi j'ai veillé à
ce qui est des des dalles qui soient
extrêmement qualitatives on aura
également une offre de commerce qui
permettra d'offrir au verrière vidéo aux
usagers un certain nombre d'offres
culinaires on aurait également un
service veligo donc de location de vélo
électrique des nouveaux arceaux vélo et
puis une attention particulière sur la
végétation qui sera les plantation
d'arbres un peu plus de 130 arbres qui
seront plantés sur cet espace pour avoir
un espace qui soit agréable qui soit
verdoyant donc réaménagement de la gare
et s'en suivra ensuite on le disait le
futur EcoQuartier gare bécane alors
quelques chiffres aussi sur ce projet
1500 logements 60 000 mètres carrés et
de pôle d'activité économique seront
construits avec aussi des commerces du
service de proximité le tout dans un
espace de plus de 70 hectares le projet
c'est un projet qu'on parle dont on
parle depuis longtemps à 50 ans en
Yvelines il a été lancé en 2013 il y a
eu la création ça c'est une date
importante en 2015 d'une axe
c'est-à-dire une zone d'aménagement
concertée quels sont les objectifs c'est
vrai qu'on parle souvent de désenclaver
la ville de La Verrière c'est le premier
objectif de ce quartier Gare bécane
c'est qu'au quartier moi je dirais c'est
de dynamiser la ville c'est le projet du
siècle pour la verrière il y a le projet
henrue au bois de l'étang pour vraiment
améliorer notre entrée de vie pour
donner une meilleure qualité de vie aux
habitants pour donner un nouveau visage
au quartier et cela va être père avec ce
projet garbecane dont on parle depuis
près 40 ans qui a un peu le vieux
serpent de mer mais là qui rentre dans
une phase extrêmement concrète on s'est
mis d'accord avec tous nos partenaires
toutes les planètes s'alignent en termes
de financement en termes de
programmation et l'idée c'est de
dynamiser la ville en ayant plus de
logements ça permet d'avoir plus de
services et notamment programmé une
maison de santé puisqu'on a zéro médecin
dans la ville là d'avoir plus
d'habitants ça permettra d'être plus
attractif pour attirer des médecins et
des services paramédicaux et puis vous
avez évoqué effectivement les commerces
on va essayer d'attirer entre 20 et 25
nouveaux commerces pour avoir une plus
grande diversité d'offres notamment en
termes de restauration en termes
d'artisans de commerçants donc ça c'est
vraiment un enjeu il y a un troisième
enjeu logiciel c'est d'avoir un coeur de
ville on a une ville avec des quartiers
qui parfois manquent de liant là l'idée
c'est d'avoir un vrai cœur de ville qui
permette de rassembler tous nos
quartiers de profiter à l'ensemble des
habitants et moi avec l'équipe on a une
vraie exigence c'est d'avoir une
architecture classique traditionnelle
qui rappelle cet esprit village auquel
on est attaché puisque la Ville de Laval
c'est vraiment un trait d'union entre 50
ans en Yvelines et sa dynamique mais
aussi la vallée de cheveux je porte de
la baie de Chevreuse et l'idée c'est de
s'inspirer de ce qu'on fait des villes
comme le plaisir Robinson c'est-à-dire
de miser sur une architecture qui
rappelle les Bours d'antan les villages
d'autrefois avec une fontaine avec des
volets battants avec des frontons avec
des yeux de boeuf avec toute cette
univers architecturale qui permet d'être
rassurant et de faire en sorte qu'on s'y
sentent vraiment bien donc c'est un
projet qui a été approuvé vous l'avez
dit après des années de travail avec la
population les partenaires
institutionnel c'est un projet aussi qui
avait suscité quelques oppositions et
l'une pas des moindres celle du maire
d'Élancourt Jean-Michel fourgaud ce qui
est devenu depuis président de 50 ans en
Yvelines qu'est-ce qui a changé et
qu'est-ce qui fait que tous les voyants
sont au vert aujourd'hui il y a beaucoup
de choses qui ont changé déjà le rapport
de confiance c'est vrai que la ville
l'agglomération le département la région
tous ces partenaires là on travaille
dans une grande confiance et ça ça
change tout ensuite sur le nombre
d'équipements publics on a pu en
suscitant la confiance est plus
ambitieux donc on aura également une
nouvelle école qui est programmée cette
maison de santé qui est également
programmée grâce au département une
nouvelle maison de quartier qui était
également dans les perspectives cette
exigence de respecter la perspective du
château on a un château extraordinaire
du 17e siècle qui appartenant et qui
appartenait à l'aide de camps de
Napoléon tout cet univers historique va
être mise en avant mais tout cela
n'était pas forcément prévu auparavant
là on a vraiment souhaité mettre
l'accent sur la préservation de la
nature et de cette qualité historique
qu'on veut mettre en avant et puis pour
terminer sur le nombre de logements
c'est vrai que le maire d'Élancourt
comme le maire de Maurepas s'inquiéter
sur un nombre démesuré de logement
c'était 1800 jusqu'à 2200 là on a réduit
à 1500 avec également cette qualité
architecturale qui rassure tout le monde
et puis également sur le nombre de
logements sociaux qui revu à la baisse
pour qu'on ait vraiment une plus grande
équilibre on a une ville avec 72% de
chez l'homme il faut qu'on revienne à
des des chiffres plus mesurés avec un
maître mot avancé en tout cas c'est la
concertation il y a eu déjà des balades
urbaines qui ont été organisées des
ateliers une réunion publique s'est
tenue le 24 novembre dernier il va y
avoir de nouvelles concertations
on va avoir des balades urbaines on va
avoir des ateliers et le maître mot
c'est esprit village trait d'union entre
la vallée de Chevreuse et 50 ans en
Yvelines et c'est attractivité pour un
autre ville encore plus attractive on a
une gare c'est extraordinaire il faut
que ce nouveau quartier dynamise la
ville attire du service des commerçants
et rendre la ville encore plus belle
qu'elle ne on disait la fin des travaux
de la gare dans un an pour ce projet
guerre bécane quel est le calendrier
espéré alors les premiers aménagements
sont attendus plutôt début du deuxième
mandat donc c'est-à-dire une durée de 4
ans tout ça prend du temps il y a des
études environnementales il y a
également le choix des promoteurs c'est
très lent c'est très long mais on avance
c'est ça qui est important c'est que
c'est du concret maintenant c'est plus
du blabla c'est du concret donc avec les
habitants premier coup de pioche on va
dire d'ici 2026 si on dirait un budget
qui est évoqué bien évidemment on a le
budget de l'école qui coûte cher on a la
également le centre de loisirs qui est
programmé la maison de santé pour la
gare le budget est connu on vous avait
cité c'est près de 10 millions d'euros
pour le parking c'est près de 10
millions d'euros pour le parvis là on
aura une ZAC une zone d'aménagement
concerté qui sera déficitaire mais qui
va permettre d'être équilibré je dirais
d'un point de vue social on aura moins
de logements plus de services pour une
ville
qu'il soit agréable à vivre avec
différents financeurs on imagine sur le
c'est 50A qui est la ménageur et puis
pour la maison de santé c'est
effectivement le département qui devrait
contribuer et puis la ville bien
évidemment qui donnera sa part nos plus
dix millions sur la gare et sur le
projet garbecane ce qu'on a un chiffre
alors c'est une ZAC donc la ZAC c'est un
équilibre entre le les équipements
publics et les logements qui seront qui
seront vendus forcément il y a qui sera
un petit peu déséquilibré puisqu'on a
réduit le nombre de logement et qu'on
est très ambitieux sur le nombre
d'équipements publics merci Nicolas
Dainville d'être venu parler de ce sujet
à ce projet à déco quartier dans la zone
gare bécane je rappelle que vous êtes le
maire de La Verrière également l'un des
vice-président de l'agglomération de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines et aussi du
département des Yvelines merci d'avoir
été avec nous merci à vous l'autre
actualité de ce week-end c'était
également le Téléthon plus de 78
millions d'euros ont été recueillis
vendredi et samedi en France contre les
maladies et génétiques rares alors quel
est le bilan dans les Yvelines ou
plusieurs animations étaient également
organisées pour récolter des fonds
exemple à Magny-les-Hameaux et aussi
dans la commune des Clayes-sous-Bois
avec Mathilde Franco et Nicolas dandry
l'Alsace à l'honneur au gymnase Chantal
Mauduit de Magny-les-Hameaux pour cette
36e édition du Téléthon et cette année
la commune a été choisie pour être le
village du secteur est dans les Yvelines
une fierté pour l'association objective
Téléthon manicois qui existe depuis 15
ans la dernière on a battu en record
nous étions à 3,83 par habitant c'est un
beau chiffre parce qu'on est un euro 13
à Paris on en est très très fier et
cette fierté fait que nous sommes
aujourd'hui
village Téléthon reconnu donc dans ce
qui est fait ici à Magny-les-Hameaux au
programme de nombreuses animations
baskets coloriage et course sportive
aujourd'hui on a fait un une course
itinérante avec plus de 30 jeunes
sapeurs-pompiers qui ont couru 13 km
avec un jeune une jeune personne
handicapée qui a 10 ans qui s'appelle
Enzo
donc voilà donc c'est ce sont ces jeunes
qui ont porté ce projet qui ont porté
Enzo pendant toute la course et cette
année nous brousse la gagnante de The
Voice 2022
était la marraine du Téléthon Mani quoi
pour la science parce que c'est
important ça peut arriver à tout le
monde et c'est une cause très importante
je pense qu'on a tous eu quelqu'un dans
notre famille atteinte d'une maladie et
c'est très compliqué et donc c'est pour
ça que je soutiens cette cause
aujourd'hui
[Musique]
j'ai choisi une chanson qui s'appelle
rise up et c'est l'histoire d'une d'un
couple
il y a un monsieur qui est en fauteuil
roulant qui a une maladie et sa femme
l'aide à gravir les montagnes en fait
avec lui et je trouvais que c'est une
chanson d'espoir et et pour bah le
Téléthon c'est quand même important de
de passer un message d'espoir aux gens
direction Les Clayes-sous-Bois une autre
célébrité était présente pour soutenir
la cause il est important dans les
moments que l'on vit de venir soutenir
d'aider d'encourager quelque part à tous
les bénévoles qui qui organisent
cette manifestation je trouve ça génial
de participer je suis très fier d'être
leurs parents au total
683401 euros ont été récoltés dans les
Yvelines un chiffre qui tend à évoluer
mais qui est tout de même en baisse par
rapport à l'année dernière ou 712000
euros avait été récolté
ressenti il y a le problème actuel il y
a eu moins de ventes à mon avis il y a
moins de ventes dans les stands tenu par
les bénévoles et si vous souhaitez faire
un don vous pouvez toujours le faire
jusqu'au vendredi 9 décembre
j'ai cueille à présent sur ce plateau
une journée de la rédaction Gabriel
Gontier bonsoir et avec vous on va
parler de théâtre
c'était il y a quelques semaines au
centre culturel le Chaplin à
Mantes-la-Jolie justement Mamadou Traoré
et Marouane harbouche vous nous avez
rejoint bonsoir à vous deux vous faites
partie des mentors de l'association je
vous propose de regarder le sujet
[Musique]
continuez bien
apprendre à interpréter un rôle tenir la
pause face au public s'écouter et
écouter les autres
laisse un peu les autres derniers aussi
important de laisser la place aussi aux
autres deux fois par semaine ils sont
une quinzaine de collégiens a participé
aux ateliers du
mis en place par l'association Jeunesse
sans frontières
soutenu par les établissements scolaires
partenaires le but est d'encadrer la
jeunesse et leur faire découvrir le
théâtre comme moyen d'expression pour
aborder les problématiques sociales
liées à la banlieue je suis là pour
apprendre de nouvelles choses pour jouer
pour connaître d'autres personnes on a
fait le tableau le tableau vivant ou
c'est un travail de groupe
2 1 tableau figé je fais que des statuts
personnels au cœur de l'accompagnement
la sensibilisation pour favoriser le
lien social et la tolérance pour cette
fin de séance là j'ai fait j'ai ramené
Yasmina qui est une ancien élève de
Clémenceau je lui laisse la parole et si
vous avez des questions n'hésitez pas
pour commencer j'aurai une question à
vous poser est-ce que vous savez
qu'est-ce que c'est le harcèlement
scolaire
pendant 15 minutes chacun a pu échanger
sur la thématique l'occasion pour
certains de se confier sur leur
expérience personnelle
on va dire il se livre et voilà c'est ce
genre de moment où on sent qu'il grandit
il grandissent par l'instant T en fait
parce que là ils ont une réflexion ils
sont dans l'échange et c'est des moments
les plus les plus riches en fait de
l'accompagnement pour finir en beauté ce
projet les jeunes fouleront les planches
pour une représentation en décembre avec
nous en plateau également nous a rejoint
un Rudy enzinga alors la représentation
elle aura lieu le 16 décembre et ce
qu'ils sont prêts
nos jeunes bien sûr là on est en pleine
préparation on arrive on va dire un
instant un peu un peu important c'est le
moment on va dire où les jeunes ils se
ressentent la pression en même temps
c'est de la pression positive parce que
c'est l'avenue du spectacle né qui les
mettent dans cet état-là en vous
travaillez avec ces jeunes sur des
thématiques notamment les probiotiques
liées à l'avant lieu là on parle aussi
d'harcèlement scolaire au travers de
votre travail pourquoi c'est un thème
qui est important à vos yeux pourquoi le
mettre le mettre en avant du coup c'est
à travers un petit peu mon expérience
sociale où j'ai travaillé dans les
collèges aussi dans les lycées qu'on a
constaté que de plus en plus les jeunes
utilisent ce moyen là d'expression en
fait l'harcèlement pour pour s'intégrer
dans un groupe pour eux ils ont
l'impression que peut-être qu'on se
liguant contre de contre les autres et
bah ils se sentiraient valorisés ils
sont tirer important et l'idée c'est un
petit peu de casser cette image là en
fait donc c'était voilà la raison pour
laquelle on a choisi le harcèlement
au-delà de cette thématique vous avez
vraiment à cœur et je l'ai vu pendant le
tournage de leur inculquer la
bienveillance c'est des valeurs qui sont
importantes pour vous et pour
l'association
essentiels très très importantes c'est
avec ce valeurs là qu'on va pouvoir
justement
combattre le harcèlement et les autres
les autres choses qui qui gangrène un
peu leur cœur donc pour nous la
bienveillance et le mot d'ordre c'est
vraiment d'accepter le les autres il y a
un rôle important celui de mentor
justement avec comment vous êtes arrivés
dans cette initiative qu'est-ce qui vous
a plu et pourquoi vous êtes joints dans
dans ce dispositif Marouane alors le
mentorat c'était un projet parmi le
grand projet ikigai donc on a accepté
dès qu'on nous a proposé en fait ce
projet surtout quand on a su que c'était
sur le thème de l'harcèlement c'est un
thème qui touche beaucoup d'enfants
aujourd'hui donc c'est un sujet qui nous
a qui nous a tout de suite donc on a
accepté de de rejoindre le projet et de
de m'entourer ces jeunes 6e des
accompagner d'un point de vue culturel
avec l'association et Mamadou Rudy
utilisait le mot de bienveillance aussi
ce que vous avez ressenti vous dans ce
travail dans ce travail qui est mené
encore actuellement ouais exactement ce
travail qu'on a mené on voulait
justement leur retranscrire nous
toutes les bonnes volontés et pour que
ça leur fasse j'ai envie de dire un
bagage un bon bagage pour la vie et
franchement si on peut aider on aide et
moi et culturel franchement c'est un bon
moyen Gabriel alors vous leur apportez
beaucoup on l'a compris mais qu'est-ce
que eux vous apportent
franchement ce qui nous apporte un
descriptible j'ai envie de vous dire
parce que c'est des enfants et quand on
parle d'enfant on parle de sujets
sensibles forcément
mais pas que ça nous donne le sourire
franchement de les voir se développer de
ce dépasser pour quelque chose qui leur
tient à cœur aussi parce que si ils sont
là aujourd'hui
parce qu'ils ont conscience aussi donc
ils veulent faire comprendre à leurs
camarades leur engagement et
la thématique sur laquelle on travaille
finalement la richesse est partagée elle
est de apprendre de part et d'autre quoi
complètement en fait on a l'impression
de de beaucoup donner au début on donne
du temps on donne de l'énergie mais on
reçoit beaucoup plus que ce que l'on
donne on reçoit des émotions des
sentiments on reçoit de la bonne humeur
de la joie de vivre de la part des
enfants on apprend à les connaître et
voilà on les voit grandir tout
simplement mais redis si on revient à ce
dispositif on le disait qui fait partie
des actions d'une association qui
s'appelle jeunesse sans frontières le
dispositif tiéka donner la parole à ces
jeunes finalement via le théâtre
pourquoi c'était important de leur
donner la parole via le théâtre pourquoi
le théâtre est un élément intéressant
de verbaliser ses émotions donc au lieu
de les exprimer à travers la violence ou
à travers des insultes à travers des
harcèlement par exemple et bah justement
le cas ça va permettre de vraiment de
creuser en soi et de et de verbaliser ça
à travers les mots donc c'est pour ça
que nous ça a été essentiel on a
commencé d'ailleurs avec avec Mamadou
ici présent on a commencé avec eux de
les prendre en main et de s'accaparer ce
on va dire un thème qui était le les
thèmes des violences et de le verbaliser
à travers le théâtre vous pensez que ça
va être une plus-value dans leur vie
plus tard de savoir s'exprimer en public
d'avoir appris toutes ces choses là avec
vous sans aucun doute parce que dès que
on est face à on est face à un adulte où
on fait un entretien par exemple on a
besoin un peu de cette confiance là de
s'exprimer de cette posture et à travers
le théâtre forcément on apprend ces
codes là de posture de tenue
d'éloquence voilà s'il y a de l'artère
l'arboratoire en fait qu'on touche en
fait et vous travaillez aussi avec les
écoles les établissements au sens
scolarisés ces enfants notamment la CPE
qui vous accompagne je crois c'est ça du
coup un gros merci d'ailleurs à Madame
venelle qui s'est fait de référente de
ce gros projet et qui nous accompagne
tout au long un peu de ce projet et je
pense qu'elle a su voir en nous en avait
su voir à travers les mentors aussi
l'investissement l'implication qu'il y a
à accompagner à donner à donner tout ce
qu'on tousse qu'on savait assez jeune là
il y a aussi du coup enfin comment
comment l'accueil les parents aussi se
dispositif que quel est votre relation
avec eux est-ce que ça leur plaît que
leur leurs enfants puissent faire du
théâtre justement oui bien sûr on va
dire que comme on va dire on est issus
du même quartier pour la plupart ou de
la même ville il y a tout de suite un
peu on va dire cette confiance qui s'est
installée et tout de suite ils ont ils
ont vu d'un bonnet je pense j'ai mal
j'ai mal penser qui que le fait qu'on
prenne en charge leurs enfants dans des
temps extrascolaires et bah c'était
c'était une belle initiative mais c'est
une belle initiative en tout cas bravo à
vous Rudi Marouane Mamadou et on va
continuer de suivre ce projet Gabriel
sur TV 78
dans la représentation qui est donc aura
lieu en décembre vous l'avez dit on a
toutes les informations merci encore
d'être venues sur ce plateau et bien sûr
la suite avec attention c'est bon vous
remercie merci beaucoup cette semaine
nous vous proposons également sur tv78
une série de reportages sur le chef
cuisine et Jérémy en bielle son
restaurant c'est large nous allons le
suivre dans la réalisation de une
recette fort du territoire c'est la
poule au pot avec des ingrédients du
pays ou Danet justement ce soir premier
numéro effectué lors des courses du chef
avec le chef et nous suivons ses courses
avec Nicolas dandry et Mathilde de
Franco
[Musique]
bonjour je me présente je suis Jérémy en
bielle chef du restaurant de l'arche
aujourd'hui je vous propose de cuisiner
la poule au pot avec la poule de Houdan
et pour ça je vous propose de
m'accompagner et de voir tous les locaux
avec qui je travaille au quotidien
[Musique]
donc la première étape c'est d'aller à
la boucherie des arts sur sur Houdan
pour récupérer de quoi faire la farce
pour la poule au pot et aussi la pièce
du boucher pour le restaurant pour le
service du jour
[Musique]
j'ai dans le secteur de la restauration
depuis à peu près une quinzaine d'années
on a quand même un beau domaine on a un
beau site on a un bon restaurant et il y
a énormément de choses à faire dessus
donc voilà après une identité sur le
restaurant je
je pense pas qu'il y en ait vraiment une
l'idée c'est de faire
du familial du voilà de la cuisine de
terroir la cuisine de grand-mère en fait
de faire simple c'est pour ça
qu'aujourd'hui on travaille avec les
locaux qui choisissent les produits pour
nous et voilà je leur fais totalement
confiance aujourd'hui sur le choix des
produits je connais pas toutes les
saisons de tout donc moi je vais voir
mon maraîcher je dis bah alors
qu'est-ce qui va arriver enfin quelle
est la fin de la saison pour tel produit
qu'est ce qui va commencer demain la
poissonnière c'est pareil voilà Nathalie
elle me dit bah tiens là en ce moment
c'est la Saint Jacques il faut y aller
et ben on met la Saint-Jacques à la
carte quand elle va me dire écoute la
Saint-Jacques c'est fini hop on arrête
et à chaque fois en fait on est dans la
communication à ce niveau là c'est eux
qui me disent
respecte tel produit pour que tu
respectes la sinusanité des produits
on va commencer par la boucherie des
arts à Houdan qui me fournit toute la
toute la viande donc là
on va faire une farce à base de veau
après on va aller chez bifreui qui est
le maraîcher on va chercher tout ce qui
est chalotes les oignons les poireaux
les carottes le persil les champignons
après on va aller chez Julien Lecoq donc
chez la ferme le coq à Lognes
où on va récupérer la poule de Houdan
salut
[Musique]
moi cette fois-ci c'est bien la fin du
reportage et je vous disais poursuivre
la suite des aventures de Jérémy Ambiel
et rendez-vous toute cette semaine dans
le 7 8 sur TV 78 bien sûr
[Musique]
et c'est l'heure de notre large page
sport dans le 7 8 avec notre journaliste
sport de la rédaction de TV 78 Michael
et midoro ce soir vous êtes de retour et
on va parler forcément pour commencer de
football c'est notre image sport du
week-end elle concerne la Coupe du monde
de football qui se tient en ce moment au
Qatar 2 images prises pendant le match
de l'équipe de France ce dimanche à 16h
face à la Pologne la première image dans
un bar de Saint-Germain-en-Laye un bar
bondé pour soutenir l'équipe de France
les supporters en fait beaucoup de bruit
à chaque but et l'ambiance était bonne
enfant ils étaient environ 150 dans
l'établissement et quelques autres en
terrasse l'autre photo a été prise après
le match de Voisins-le-Bretonneux en
dernier district controlfc Mantois les
vices chinois ont filé directement voir
la rencontre après le coup de sifflet
final aux alentours de 16h30 c'était
d'ailleurs le cas pour beaucoup de
joueurs à des Yvelines tous sports
confondus les matchs étaient programmés
pour la plupart aux alentours de 15
heures au total
14,32 millions de Français ont regardé
cette victoire de la France contre la
Pologne ils seront sûrement encore plus
nombreux ce samedi à 20h face à
l'Angleterre l'Angleterre moi
malheureusement le match était à 15h
donc j'ai raté une partie du match
nos invités d'ailleurs sport sont
revenus en plateau avec sel lyonnaise et
son coach René et mamie vous y croyez la
victoire de l'équipe de France
bien sûr j'espère après je suis étudié
entre la France et le Portugal en fait
et face à l'Angleterre vous avez pas
peur c'est quand même une équipe un peu
plus relevée on va dire qui se présente
pour les Bleus mais ils sont prêts donc
je pense que bon ils vont en faire une
bouchée bon on va comprendre dans un
instant de la très belle médaille de
bronze d'Axel Duriez qu'il a obtenu au
championnat du monde ce sera dans un
instant on va poursuivre avec les
résultats sports du weekend et on
continue à parler de football toujours à
Voisins-le-Bretonneux en jouet donc ce
weekend en Dr de district comme je l'ai
dit précédemment voisin le Bretonneux
recevait l'équipe 3 du FC Mantois les
vicie noir ont remporté ce choc une
belle victoire de 1 sur leur terrain et
qui fait du bien au classement le voisin
FC monte sur le podium l'équipe est
troisième avec 15 points et distant son
adversaire du jour le championnat est
toujours dominé par lime et qui caracole
en tête avec 20 points et 6 victoires en
8 journées comme toujours mais le
championnat national 2 voici repart de
l'avant après une défaite contre Racing
Colombes 92 la semaine dernière les
pistiaquer se sont imposés 2-1 sur leur
pelouse face à Vannes les buteurs Amadou
Konaté et check Touré à la 77e minute
après 12 journées disputées Poissy et 2e
avec 25 points et le club peut toujours
espérer monter en fin de saison on
jouait également sur les terrains de
régional 2 plusieurs matchs étaient au
programme ce week-end trap c'est un posé
deux à zéro sur le terrain de l'ES
parisienne de zéro également pour
l'équipe de du FC Mantois sur son
terrain contre Garen Colomb Conflans
gagne 2 1 face à adamoa Poissy 2
s'impose 3-0 face à Champigny enfin
grosse contreperformance de Houilles
défait sur son terrain face à Ivry US 2
sur le score de 1 à 0 le championnat est
toujours dominé par Argenteuil Conflans
et deuxième et Houilles et 3e le rugby
est le championnat de fédéral 2 ça
jouait ce dimanche dans ce championnat
de fédéral de plaisir qui veut monter en
fin de saison a perdu le choc face au
harassé sur le score de 21 13
contre-performance qui les empêchent de
rester sur le podium ils sont 5e à
l'heure actuelle de son côté Versailles
perd d'un petit point sur le terrain du
Rheu 28 à 27 les Versailles sont 7e le
basket que s'est-il passé sur les
terrains de national de féminine en
National de les féminine du Chesnay à
Versailles se sont imposés à ces
fascinant sur leur parquet face à
Saint-Amand Hainaut Basket le score 68 à
54 une victoire qui permet au Chesnay
Versailles d'être toujours à la
quatrième place du classement le bilan
de l'équipe 6 victoires et 4 défaites
depuis le début de la saison on termine
avec du cyclisme sur piste et j'ai envie
de vous dire cocorico cocorico
effectivement championnat championne du
monde en titre de vitesse individuelle
la française Mathilde gros qui
s'entraîne presque quotidiennement au
Vélodrome national de 50 ans en Yvelines
a remporté ce samedi soir à Londres la
Ligue des champions de cyclisme sur
pistance sprint elle devient la première
française à s'imposer dans cette
compétition disputée en cinq étapes à
sprinteuse a remporté quatre des cinq
manches loto française Marie divine quoi
mais ce classe 9e de l'épreuve la Ligue
des champions qui pourrait revenir
l'année prochaine au vélo de national de
50 ans en Yvelines
de gros la semaine dernière au vélo
national en remportant cette manche
justement de vitesse individuelle au
Vélodrome national merci pour suivre
pour les 2024 l'un des visages français
à suivre pour CIO de Paris bien sûr à
domicile avec ce vélo drone national on
continue cette édition avec un très beau
résultat vous en disait quelques mots au
début du 7 8 c'est du tumbling il est
licencié aux classes sous bois et Axel
Duriez vient de remporter la médaille de
bronze au mondiaux de Tumbling c'était à
Sophia en Bulgarie nous avons la chance
de l'avoir en compagnie je le disais de
son coach qui est infidèle du plateau on
a le plaisir de le recevoir souvent René
et Bamy qu'est-ce que ça vous fait
d'avoir cette médaille de bronze vous
êtes venus avec d'ailleurs autour du
coup ça vous fait quoi Excel ça fait un
très grand honneur déjà puisque c'est
toujours un rêve de gagner face au plus
grand ou même de faire une médaille face
au plus grand aujourd'hui j'ai pu faire
cette médaille se battre certains grands
que j'ai toujours rêvé de battre puis
donc pour moi c'est un rêve
oui j'ai réalisé oui parce que
à chaque fois que je fais une
compétition assez importante dès que le
résultat est tombé je passe déjà à la
prochaine je pense déjà au prochain
compétition qui arrive donc réaliser oui
j'ai dû à réaliser mais je suis déjà sur
mes prochains objectifs c'est pas un
aboutissement pour vous c'est peut-être
la suite d'autres choses mais vous
l'avez fêté quand même cette médaille
rassurée
j'ai fait un peu la fête avec tout le
monde toute l'équipe de France toutes
les personnes qui étaient là et puis en
rentrant chez moi j'ai vu ma famille et
tout le monde m'a félicité et relais ce
que vous avez fait la fête vous bien
[Musique]
je suis très fier parce que je pensais
qu'elle arriverait beaucoup plus tard le
plus tôt que prévu donc voilà donc les
inattendu donc dans ce cas là enfin on
fait encore plus la fête parce que on se
dit bah voilà faut profiter on ne sait
pas quand elle sera la prochaine 17 ans
c'est bien ça absolument c'est le plus
jeune de la compétition et je crois que
c'est la première médaille masculine
pour le dueling français si je dis pas
de bêtises depuis 2001
est-ce que vous réalisez justement côté
entraîneur côté athlète directement
celui qui a fait la performance Axel moi
je réalise oui puisque c'est optus la
dernière personne qui a fait une
médaille au championnat du monde c'était
c'est le kiné qui m'a accompagné sur
cette compétition donc Nicolas Fournial
qui du coup c'était une joie de fêter
cette médaille avec lui sachant que
c'était le dernier album c'était le
témoin
pendant la compétition donc c'était
vraiment assez symbolique cette image
vous le suivait et derrière bah voilà il
est ramené aussi médaille donc le
passage de témoin est assuré vous en
tant qu'entraîneur quel regard vous
portez sur cette performance et
justement cette première depuis 2001 euh
ben
une très grande fierté et
Axel surprendre de jour en jour parce
que je pense que même si moi je ça me
paraissait très très difficile lui aussi
officine mais dans Au Coin dans un coin
de sa tête je pense que il avait en
ligne de mire d'avoir une médaille il se
dit rien n'est impossible il a raison la
preuve médaille mais moi c'est vrai que
je l'envisageais pas ça tout de suite
donc là d'avoir fait ça enfin avec accès
c'est vrai que depuis que je suis depuis
qu'il a 11 ans toutes les compètes qu'il
fait il revient avec une médaille il
n'arrêtait qu'une seule sortie
internationale il a raté que en
catégorie 15 ans ou en plus c'est pas
une erreur vraiment technique c'est
parce que la piste est un peu trop court
pour lui mettre une activité qui a
dépassé les
la dépasse la réception pour la dernière
envole mais sinon à chaque fois qu'il a
levé le bras pour se présenter ben
chaque fois il sortait avec une super
performance donc bah je pense que voilà
il a c'est un sans grand
championnes aux anciennes performances à
vous n'aviez pas encore la petite
barbichette qui est apparue sur notre
visage mais vous disiez alors c'est pas
un aboutissement du coup une étape
supplémentaire en quoi c'est un peu
impulsé peut-être une dynamique
supplémentaire notre parcours vous avez
17 ans mais en quoi cette médaille va
vous aider pour la suite vous pensez bah
c'est comme une source de motivation de
se dire bah que la prochaine compétition
internationale où je suis bah il faut
que je fasse les mêmes résultats c'est
bien mais mieux encore c'est un rêve et
puis de me dire que maintenant j'ai ma
place et que je dois m'améliorer pour
augmenter de place et finir premier et
rester premier le plus longtemps que je
pourrais voilà Mickaël il y en a un qui
est heureux bah c'est vous justement ce
que vous lui suivez depuis quelques
années exactement
11 ans à peu près et j'ai pu voir un
petit peu l'évolution vous a annoncé
comme un crack je m'en souviens la
première fois que que je suis mieux au
club des clés souvent on m'a dit Axel
c'est un cra qui va remporter plein de
médailles finalement c'est le cas c'est
le cas où vous remportez plusieurs
médailles mais comment vous faites pour
justement garder la tête froide Axel
parce que tout le monde vous en sens
tout le monde dit que vous êtes un crack
comment on fait pour garder la tête
froide bah je sais pas c'est j'ai
toujours été comme ça un peu j'ai pour
moi les médailles
ça représente si une certaine
concrétisation mais voilà sans plus je
me dis que j'ai toujours quelqu'un
derrière moi qui va me rattraper un jour
ou l'autre donc
et je pense aussi chrono il est pour
beaucoup aussi dans dans l'encadrement
aussi de Axel oui je pense que ouais
c'est vrai qu'on a eu des moments aussi
difficiles parce que c'est vrai que ça
c'est un duo qui quand on fait la
performance oui on passe des points de
moins difficile et seulement sont
nécessaires et c'est le moment arrivé
justement à chaque fois presque au
moment de l'échéance parce qu'on a
besoin de ça pour pouvoir mais sinon bah
voilà c'est des petits moments manquent
difficilement la tension sur le truc et
puis maintenant voilà c'est ça roule
comme se déroulettes parce qu'on se
connaît super bien on est complémentaire
moi je sais comment il fonctionne c'est
comment fonctionne et puis là la machine
est lancée donc on a plus trop
difficultés à ce niveau là quoi et vous
en tant que coach maintenant c'est quoi
votre message c'est de lui dire
attention maintenant il y a la médaille
d'argent aller chercher il faut aller il
faut toujours viser un peu plus haut je
suis honnête que je vais te mettre avec
vous parce qu'en fait c'est vrai que je
ne rejoins jamais envisage de ce
discours là mais non c'est vrai que
quand je vois qu'il a été capable de la
troisième marche c'est vrai que
maintenant je vais pas m'arrêter là et
j'aimerais je vais on va tout faire
ensemble pour essayer d'aller
c'est ce qu'on aimerait faire donc voilà
et porter ou les couleurs des
Clayes-sous-Bois aussi
est arrivé mais en tout cas on l'a dans
un coin de la tête et puis on aimerait
bien que voilà que ça monte crescendo et
que Ben à une de ses compètes ira ils
reviennent avec la médaille d'or autour
du cou la médaille d'or justement dans
combien de temps Axel est-ce que est-ce
qu'il y a un objectif ah bah si un
objectif si la prochaine compétition
internationale bien évidemment le but
c'est voilà la gagner après on verra en
fonction de ce qui se passera dans le
temps mais le but c'est la prochaine
compétition internationale la gagner
arrête si c'est pas possible faire mieux
que cette fois et après on verra bien la
suite pour vous il y a une étape de
coupe du monde en Azerbaïdjan c'est ça
du 16 au 20 du 16 au 20 février donc ça
c'est là où vous êtes en pleine
préparation vous allez rentrer en phase
de préparation voilà ça c'est à dire
qu'on va commencer à tester un nouveau
programme pour pour représenter en
Angleterre dans dans un an donc voilà
s'il y aura plein d'étapes du monde
comme ça qui vont nous permettre de voir
comment la le programme passe comment il
est jugé comment il est évalué par les
juges donc voilà
nickel c'est une dernière question ou
rappelez peut-être une info parce qu'il
y a
vos prochaines performances on espère
avec des médailles d'argent ou d'or
voilà c'est tout le mal qu'on peut vous
souhaiter merci d'être passé en plateau
tous les réseaux on termine Michael
cette page sport avec une dernière
information et une date à retenir pour
les passionnés de cyclisme ce samedi 10
décembre en fin d'après-midi le vélo de
national de 50 ans et demi va cueillir
le gala star empire c'est un événement
qui réunit depuis 2019 sur la piste 50
chinoise des athlètes de Roland comme
Quentin Lafargue Sébastien vigiou encore
Mathilde gros la structurelinoise
ouvrira ses portes dès 17h et le moment
fort sera vers 20h si vous êtes
intéressé et intéressé il reste quelques
places à la vente merci Michael pour
toutes ces précisions
allez ce rendez-vous pourrait vous
intéresser si vous envisagez de faire
des travaux de rénovation énergétique
Montigny-le-Bretonneux organise son
premier rendez-vous de la Réno c'est
demain mardi de 19h à 21h30 à l'hôtel de
ville sur place ou pour avoir des
conseils des informations sur les
différents financements possibles pour
effectuer vos travaux échanger aussi
avec les professionnels du secteur le
rendez-vous se déroulera en deux étapes
une conférence d'une heure puis des
ateliers stand pour rencontrer les
experts cela s'adresse à tous l'entrée
est libre avant de vous laisser on jette
un dernier coup d'oeil à la météo de
demain
et malheureusement demain matin sera
brumeux dans les Yvelines et très frais
comptés 2 degrés à Mantes-la-Jolie
Versailles et Houdan 1 degré à
Rambouillet dans l'après-midi les
températures n'augmenteront que très peu
3 degrés à Rambouillet ce sera quatre
degrés à Versailles ou dans et
Mantes-la-Jolie et ce mardi à 6 décembre
c'est la Saint Nicolas voilà c'est la
fin de ce 7 8 merci de votre fidélité on
se retrouve dès demain pour une nouvelle
édition belle soirée sur TV 78
[Musique]